[Music]
mr. Sakawa
may I present miss Roxanne cause it is a
great pleasure the pleasure's all mine
[Music]
I'm with International Committee of the
Red Cross our demands all political
prisoners must be freed it is up to the
government if there is blood it will be
on their hands no one has to die
we'll have to someday
[Music]
he's always smooth by your work he must
love opera
for him he avoids his operas I'm Sookie
hello buzzer yes Porter Porter
is it true the government is considering
shooting his own guava vanilla sized to
pin it on the rebels
we need to free your brothers and
sisters
we will not surrender to these
government criminals
we hear her only her
the good stolen a massacre we are masa
how did I do
we will not last long human so let her
go unique here now more than four
[Music]
but we'll it's a weekend without them
when they heard the beautiful always
perhaps they will find a solution
[Music]
I think I should say
[Music]
I want you to sing loudly enough let
these animals outside can hear
it's time
[Music]